there was a military theorist john boyd
and he said something like great fighter
pilots use their superior judgment to
make sure they never have to get into
situations to use their superior force
and i think the same is true for
understanding medic theory it doesn't
give you the ability to just snap your
fingers and not be social creatures but
it does give you the foresight to see
bad situations coming and potentially
avoid it
jonathan b welcome to the show
thanks for having me chris excited to be
on so the first time that we met was
through david perrell actually and we
went out for dinner now david is a man
who has two modes of uh culinary
experience and he either goes uh
chick-fil-a
or fighting hobos outside of a food
truck or he goes the most expensive
steak restaurant in town i've noticed
this since spending time with him he's
got he's very sort of bar belly when it
comes to what he wants to do with food
but thankfully we went to the we went to
the next nice steak restaurant yeah
although i
wouldn't mind uh fine fighting for a
taco uh next time with you when i'm in
austin so david david's oddly uh
experienced at that which is right uh
concerned but yeah he's incredible given
how small and scrawny he is
got a new girlfriend that's like
training him up or something making him
eat like a surplus of calories uh he
once took me for lunch
at some french place on congress and i
was in flip-flops and a pair of shorts
and it was just wags and like little
tiny model dogs but anyway anyway enough
about david perrell um
are you trained in renee girard
the philosopher have you got some sort
of like gerardian accreditation
uh perhaps i have the most girardian of
accreditations which is uh you know
being self-taught um gerard himself was
trained in uh history in indiana
university and before that he was an
archivist in france but uh you know he
neither made any contributions to you
know our arc
being a librarian or uh history and the
avenues that he did make significant
contributions to uh in you know in
anthropology and theology and psychology
he was all self-taught so i suppose the
answer that's a nice way of saying no
followed in his footsteps did it the
right way yes i uh i i was trained in um
continental philosophy um and however
gerard is not read at all in the in the
academy unless in literary criticism
um and so
i i was sort of introduced to gerard as
a sophomore and i had to read the
gerardian canon so to speak myself with
a couple of friends of course that's
what always makes the journey fun who is
he and what's the core insight of his
work
yeah so uh he recently passed away in
2015 but his life is probably not as
interesting as
as his key insights are and i would say
that his most fundamental insight is we
don't often desire things for the things
themselves but for what the things say
about us
and the way he makes this argument is to
delineate two types of desire physical
desire which he which is directed at the
object
and metaphysical desire which is
directed at what the object uh
says about me let me give you some quick
examples you know take any activity
really and we can see both strands of
desire at work in different
circumstances if i desire to have sex
for example it could be for pleasure it
could be for intimacy experiences in the
moment and that would be for physical
desire a desire for experience but i can
also desire to have sex
uh for what having sex with a certain
type of person says about me right and
this is how as you know from uh you know
being in nightlife how a lot of people
do live their lives right they're not
really in it for the pleasure they're in
it because they want to be someone and
that's the psychology of the casanova or
the or the don juan or the coquette and
this
this sort of insight expands across all
of our decisions right we could
you know take on a job because of what
the job says about us but we could also
take on the job because we actually like
the activity in and of itself and so
that is gerard's core insight that
there's two different strands of desire
and a dominant strand metaphysical
desire is actually not aimed at the
object itself but what the object says
about me it's a desire to be rather than
a desire to experience
is this different to signaling or how
does this relate to signaling
yeah
it's interesting because it's almost
signaling to oneself in some sense right
because it's
you know the person who's motivated by
metaphysical desire even if no one sees
you uh you know having sex with a really
beautiful woman you are still rewarded
by that whereas when we commonly think
about signaling uh the reward is always
external
now just let me elaborate a bit more on
this concept of metaphysical desire
because because i think we need to draw
that implications a bit more when we ask
gerard when we poke him really hard and
say well what do we really want to be
right what is this desire to be really
aimed at gerard thinks we all desire to
exist in great measure so perhaps not
unlike nietzsche's will to power gerard
identifies a key human motivational
force as this unrelenting drive to
establish ourselves to be greater than
life even in seemingly non-prideful and
ordinary individuals gerard thinks we
want to establish our being to be the
most real like a social reality social
reality like being being seen and being
recognized to be long-lasting and
permanent right the denial of death and
wanting to leave a legacy and also the
last one is to exert power in our social
world now gerard thinks that this type
of being is terribly elusive and we can
never achieve it so he's very
pessimistic on the human condition that
we're just
pushed by this drive that we can never
fully satisfy and for this for him this
is what it means to be to live in
original sin
now the last point that i'll make i know
i've been rambling on for a long time
is
how do we
satisfy this drive and that's where
mimesis comes into play
we satisfy this drive this desire to be
to exist in great measure by obtaining
objects
associated with models who we already
conceive of as existing in great measure
be it a celebrity be it a
slightly more established co-worker be
it attractive man or woman we look for
models around the world to tell us what
we should want what is the core of our
identity and i think this is no uh
in no other place is this better
established than in celebrity
advertisement and the one line that i
think that always gives it away for me
is jordan's sneakers taglines be like
mike the advertisements of basketball
sneakers tell you nothing about the
physical qualities of the basketball
sneakers the bounce the lightness the
grip or even the price but it's
promising you something you want all the
more being be like mike and so that is
gerard's sort of core psychological
system from which all of his social
anthropology anthropological and
eschatological insights eventually flow
from
gerard should have been a nightclub
promoter he would have crushed it in the
nightlife game so here's an interesting
example that i like to use
you
decide not to go on a night out with a
bunch of your friends your friends go on
the night out they wake up the next
morning they're hungover but a little
bit later on once they've got their
pizza order out of the way you give
someone a ring or you give them a text
and you say hey man how was last night
so many times the first thing that
someone will reply with will be dude it
was awesome there was so many girls
there last night you go
hang on
i asked how the night was i didn't ask
who the other consumers of the thing
that you were consuming were so right
people that buy an iphone
mostly don't buy an iphone because david
beckham also has an iphone they buy an
iphone for the core competence that the
product gives them it's got a camera and
it can make calls and it's got good
battery life and stuff like that right
somebody so sure about that i mean think
about all the cases of uh people selling
their livers for an iphone i imagine
they're not doing a rational analysis
saying oh my liver is worth for you know
the the camera the all this stuff i do
think the iphone is actually a great
example of
or actually you and i might purchase it
for physical desire right but i'm sorry
to interrupt you but i think for a lot
of people it is a sort of status symbol
it is a sort of metaphor i would agree
as a status symbol you're probably right
there but certainly when you compare it
to a night a nightclub event totally the
the the core
feature of the product that is going on
a night out
is the other consumers of the product
you can go on a night out to the same
event week on week the dj could play the
same set the sound and the lights could
be exactly the same the drinks prices
could be the same the service could be
the same but if you change
the other people that go and consume
that product because they are such a big
influence on your night and it's not
just some sort of woo ephemerals like
uh
status signally thing they actually
impact your night in a physical way like
if there's loads of guys that are
aggressive and dancing like that
actually changes your experience so it's
not totally totally woo but
it is the most important thing about
nightlife are the other people that
consume that product and it's so
interesting to see that because you go
well
hang on what does this mean from a
product design perspective it means that
actually what i need to do is create a
product
not that's the best but that attracts
people that other people want to be
around
so for a lot of nightclubs that means
getting girls in if you bring girls in
girls don't have a problem with more
girls but both girls and guys have a
problem with more guys yeah
yeah totally well first thing i'll say
is i think we should be extremely
comfortable thinking about the context
of gerard within uh romance and dating
because it's romance and dating where he
goes to his canonical examples as well
and i think perhaps a reason uh he he
goes there is that we traditionally
think that in romance and dating that's
where our physical urges are the
strongest right will could be motivated
with sex but even in this domain gerard
shows if you'll excuse upon that our
desires are helplessly penetrated by the
desires of others right even in such a
domain that's dominated by a physical
strong desire we can be hopelessly
mediated by other people just think
about our other sort of less strongly
physical domains political intuitions
philosophical opinions uh and all the
rest the other thing i'll say is and i i
read a pretty interesting book called
the very important persons i think
you'll really enjoy it it's not actually
yes she's been on the show yeah she was
great you know what i actually i
actually know that because i think i i
went from the show to the book and and
that's exactly what the book says right
the way that you get guys to spend is
you get uh more women there you add the
gays of the woman that um sort of enable
the men to be more competitive with each
other and drive bottle service what you
see
in nightclubs specifically we didn't do
this so we ran
events that were high volume low cost
we were putting a thousand to 2018 to 21
year olds in so it wasn't about bottles
and shows although we've dabbled in a
little bit of that and obviously i've
been to my fair share of events like
that what you'll see in nightclubs and
anyone can go and check this out if
you're in a city like miami or new york
that has big bottle show type events
look at the way that they position the
most expensive tables in the club
they're always within uh seeing distance
of each other
reason being that you want to have one
table start to dick measure with the
other they want to order a medium-sized
show to begin with probably probably a
little bit bigger than they anticipated
because they want a little bit of that
conspicuous consumption going on but
then another table's like yo [ __ ] that
dude get the amex out let's let's let's
wipe those guys under the table and then
you have this game back and forth so in
a couple of venues they'll be opposite
each other like the most antagonistic
way that you could position people but
they're always going to be able to see
each other because you want to create
that competition yeah yeah and let me uh
pull us
even a bit further in the theory because
we're all i think we're all giving
examples good examples of instances
where mimesis and metaphysical desire
makes us converge but the other and i
think people commonly uh misunderstand
this in gerard the opposite is true as
well metaphysical desire can also enable
us to diverge from the group because
it's almost the same extension of the
same logic right the logic of
metaphysical desire that i just said was
do we want to acquire objects associated
with models with a heightened degree of
being well the inverse logic is true as
well we also want to distance ourselves
away from objects
associated with models with a deficiency
of being i mean a trite way to say this
is we want to wear the same brands of
the sneakers as the cool kids in high
school but also want to make damn sure
that we don't wear the same brands as
the not cool kids right as a social
outcast in high school and so mimesis
can equally lead us to diverge as it
leads us to converge and i think a great
example here i'll give you is this
rather i was in college and i had an
acquaintance from freshman year and he
was very concerned with distributive
justice so i think progressive economics
and and i thought you know
what a kind guy he's always caring about
the poor
and you know i got to know him a lot
better and this acquaintance confessed
to me uh that
in sophomore year that uh he was
actually very motivated by the hatred of
his richer peers
rather than the direct caring
of the of the of the poor um in fact he
grew up in a he was a middle class and
grew up in an upper middle class uh uh
sort of
uh you know
uh school district and it was out of
that resentment that he basically just
flipped the logic of the people that he
resented on its head and and you know
what's really funny with these types is
he's now an investment banking right
because he didn't have a problem with
making a lot of money at all in fact the
reason he loathed it so much was because
he wanted it so much but there were
people sort of stopping them there and
so
um the reason i thought this was
important highlight is because i think
our societies are very conscious of
conformity as being inauthentic right as
being determined by the group but
there's a form of divergence from the
group out of this resentment that i see
proliferating in society today that is
just as inauthentic and just as
determined by the group no less than
pure conformity and so mimesis and
metaphysical desire really entrap us in
every direction we go and this romantic
line that gerard thinks we're all in is
that we have this authentic core of the
self with these social layers added on
and all we have to do is peel back these
social layers but gerard says not so
fast you're confusing originality
originality and difference for
authenticity but that is not so i just
want to make sure that we highlight that
as well
is that the positive and negative
mimesis is that how that's labeled
precisely so there's a positive phase of
mimesis where you're converging to the
model and then there's a negative phase
of mimesis where you want to diverge
from the model
yeah it's um
it's strange when you think about
what the real motivations are for the
things that you do how much how much is
it that i'm
believing the things that i believe or
wanting the things that i want because
other people want them or because other
people that i don't like want them like
how much am i pushing away from stuff i
don't want to be like and how much am i
going towards things that i do
there's a
eric weinstein calls it reflexive
heterodoxy
that whatever the mainstream narrative
is whatever's opposite to that must be
true because always the mainstream is
lying and you go well
that's just as low resolution like
that's no more sophisticated it's still
a one and a zero the only difference is
you chose the zero instead of the one
yeah yeah or another way to put it the
way i thought about it is one and
negative one right you want to be not
correlated you want to be zero you you
want to be like not correlated to the
group but instead you're just sort of
flipping everything
on its head and my point is and i think
what you're saying is agreeing with this
in society we can easily identify
conformity as being inauthentic as being
determined by the group um but people
are just starting to gain a sort of
awareness of why uh
sort of
carving one's own path and having bold
breaking away from the group can be just
as uh fraught and inauthentic going back
to the dating example one of the common
pieces of advice for people when they're
creating their tinder profile
is to have photos with other women or
other men right if you're a girl with
other guys if you're a guy with other
girls is that shows that you are
somebody that is already around that i
need you don't want to choose like the
worst looking friends that you've got
right you're going to choose what look
like high value
friends
yeah um
and
you know
i i don't think gerard would have much
more to say than the ground that we've
already already covered right we want to
show uh people we consider to have
a higher degree of being as already
desiring desiring us um and you know
this is the logic behind why you know
more attractive and seemingly successful
people are used behind advertisements
right there's also a um
a funny sort of cascading effect that
you see
someone that isn't a particularly good
looking guy in celebrity culture will
start to go out with some girl who is
super hot and everyone will go hang on a
second what's he doing with her that's a
little bit strange
if they break up his next three
girlfriends are always absolute smoking
hot winners it's okay what what why is
that well it's like well that person
must have noticed something about this
guy that nobody else was able to see
and then there's sort of this like
mimetic echo that goes over time
because super high status girl number
one and then two and three and four
yeah and i think you're you're really
hitting at the intuition of the world
and the very strange world that gerard
is leading us towards
um it's not a world where you know we
use reason or even we use our own
experience to really diligence things to
see the true essence of things but it's
it's a world of associations right that
we make decisions uh through
associations and and that i think is uh
you know trite and reductionist but i
think accurate uh intuition of what
world we're stepping into what drew you
to gerard you've dedicated a lot of time
to thinking and learning about one guy
you know i i grew up as a stem science
person
um and i think
a problem with the
intellectual
current of today
is that we're
under-appreciating
the social dimensions of the self and
and this is an argument that you're
going to hear from the the left and the
right by the way
um
you know maybe this will help you know
plato had a conception of the soul as
being consisting of three parts right
there's appetite we've discussed desire
for sex for food pleasure there's reason
that we know very well
and then there's spirit right the soul
the part of the soul that desires social
goods honor glory fame and if i
even if this concept is not reflective
of the most uh
sophisticated academic positions of the
day i think
uh the popular cultural current
conceives of humans
completely removed of the spirited part
of the soul it conceives humans as
rational utility maximizing machines and
i think you know how many times have you
heard this said in silicon valley you
know we're about robots trying to
maximize happy chemicals squirting in
our brains or take how uh gdp is
important as a measure almost like the
ultimate measure of a country's sort of
accomplishment right because gdp is
fundamentally that it's it's the ability
to quantify our appetite
and what i think gerard does is gerard
psychology really spells out the a third
and
you know
from my perspective hidden part of human
nature and that's the social
spirited part so put in another way
gerard reveals the logic of our
illogical part of ourselves
or
he rationalizes our irrationalities and
and this has devastating consequences
not just about how we ought live our
lives
but even in geopolitical events an
example that i gave you and i you know
gave in the first lecture where you know
your listeners are more than welcome to
listen to it's out today
is
china now in the uh late night in the
90s and certainly in the 2000s the
dominant view of the west was that the
economic liberalization of china would
be welcomed by the world and the long
short of the argument would be you know
china's rise would also make the west uh
richer through cheaper goods and that
people would be happy with this rise now
you can fundamentally see that the
assumption here is that we are rational
utility maximizing creatures if we get
three oreos for three dollars you know
we're less happy than if we get four
oreos for three dollars but gerard went
against the public opinion in 2007 this
was the height of sino-american optimism
he went against the crowd and he said
that
uh the china's wrong that even if china
did make uh the west richer which is
what ended up happening
as relativistic social creatures
concerned more for social standing the
closing of the gap is what both parties
will focus on the chinese will not be
happy be much happier that they are
closer to americans instead the fact
that they're closer makes them more
envious and the same is true for the
west that the fact that they are
absolutely richer matters very little to
drop in relativistic comparison and so
it's this fundamentally different alien
but i think more revealing lens of
viewing humans not as rational agents
but as social spirited creatures is why
gerard was so uh so pulled me in
was that a big shock given that you were
coming from a stem background
oh it was a tremendous shock but it was
also why it was
uh you know really interesting i feel
like if i
you know had grown up with that
intuition in mind then all this would be
obvious and it kind of seems obvious to
me now right after after studying for
him for so long
but uh yeah it was a tremendous shock
and
you know gerard really is and i can't
emphasize this enough attacking the
fundamental pillars of the modern west
because think about what the answer to
the question where does normative
authority where do we gain assurance of
our values gerard's answer is the
dominant force is through by looking at
other people but what does the modern
west say there's two answers one
speaking very broad strokes here is the
enlightenment reason we use reason to
figure that out the other again very
broadly here romanticism that there's a
a core of authenticity but as we've
already discussed both gerard uh
subsumes under the power of the social
part of ourselves that we are
fundamentally social creatures we are
like co-vibrating violin strings and
this uh and we probably don't have time
to talk about this but the political
implications uh are are just tremendous
and and really really earth-shattering
for for for the modern west how does
understanding gerard make life better
then
yeah so the first thing i'll say is
gerard is going to be very unsatisfying
if you're looking for him to give you
prescriptive answers the the real
prescriptive answer that he that he
tells you is to withdraw to leave the
world behind in his later book he would
hold holder lin a 19th century german
poet who literally pun intended hold
himself up in a tower for the last
decades of his life as the example
par-ex loans
now i i've obviously i have not been
satisfied with that response i'm not
holed up in the tower and so i thought a
lot about the implications of uh of his
theory and how how out we live given
that and i have a few sort of broad
stroke answers here
the first answer i'll give is
um just a mere fact of gaining awareness
of
the social dimension of ourselves and
the logic of mimesis is tremendously
helpful
it's not helpful that it will stop
making you be memetic right away but it
will give you the foresight to avoid bad
situations because you can see them
coming from a mile away and the analogy
i like to use is you know there was a
military theorist john boyd and he said
something like i don't have to
paraphrase that great fighter pilots
use their superior judgment to make sure
they never have to get into situations
to use their superior force and i think
the same is true for understanding
memetic theory it doesn't give you uh
the ability to just snap your fingers
and not be social creatures but it does
give you the foresight uh to see bad
situations coming and potentially avoid
it so that's the first thing i'll say
just rational understanding is
tremendous tremendously helpful
the second thing i want to say is that
these two separate desires physical
desire right the desire for the object
activity in itself the job for
experience metaphysical desire desire
for being for gerard
this metaphysical desire i'm sorry this
physical desire while not always being
good right you can be gluttonous and
that can ruin you um but this
metaphysical desire is almost always bad
that'll just lead you from one wild
goose hunt to the next
and so one immediate and quite
a simple conclusion there is well let's
find activities where i like in and of
itself right and for me this was
switching from uh and again but both
degrees but and switching from cs to to
philosophy and i think it's helpful for
our listeners to conceive of these two
desires as really fighting for real
estate and so the more you push one or
the more that the physical desire is
there the less you have to draw on
for metaphysical desire
and so for me switching to an activity
philosophy that was much more
interesting to me um it meant that i
didn't have to pull on the motivational
forces of of social prestige and social
affirmation as much
um so that that's the the second way um
the third is you know one can decrease
metaphysical desire directly and i think
there's
two ways to do that and remember
metaphysical desire is simply a very
prideful drive right of wanting to be
greater than life and i think the two
ways to do that
one is failure
if you've ever just failed so hard an
activity that you feel your entire ego
and self is shattered anyone who's gone
through something like that knows that
that's there's an you know opportunity
to to be more humble and let go of pride
but i think the inverse is true as well
is to achieve the thing that you always
wanted to do and see it as as deeply
lacking right this uh this the way out
is through so to speak almost a form of
personal accelerationism
um
and the last thing i'll probably say is
if you think that you can
escape from the mises from wanting
recognition then you really haven't
realized how deeply this drive is
embedded into the human nature that that
you would fundamentally be uh
irrecognizable without it it's like
asking you know what would a human look
like if they didn't breathe right it's
just it's just constitutive of what a
human is
and so
what i would warn people um and this is
what i also was trying to get at with
negative imitation uh negative mimesis
is that
don't try to be a loner
the solution isn't to escape from all
forms of social construction but to find
a type of social construction that
from a sober perspective
influences and directs you to the type
of desires that you actually want
practically speaking uh it's you know
finding a bunch of friends who who also
like to do philosophy with you or
whatever your sort of passion is
and so those are the things that i would
uh that i would say like how
what are the immediate things that we
can do from this theory
is mimesis falsifiable
this seems a little bit to me like
you do the thing that everybody else
does
that's mimesis you do the thing opposite
to everybody else does
that's negative mimesis that
it seems to me a little bit like gerard
might have been a bit sort of sneaky
with his unfalsifiable theory here
yeah well that's a great question but
the first thing i'll say is
not
every act is mediated by the group right
again
you can pursue sex
or pleasure itself
not because of what it says about you or
not because of any sort of social force
so there's a large swath of activity
that is neither uh positive nor negative
in the mises right so we don't have to
in other words we don't have to label
everything as positive and negative
mimesis
and but i think you bring up a very
interesting and broader point which is
what is the nature of proof in gerard
um and i think when you get to these you
know philosophical theories as you do
hegel uh or or maybe nietzsche i think
the only
form of proof that is available perhaps
um i might walk back on that statement
but i think the only or the strongest
form of proof available is introspection
right try to what gerard is saying here
is he's giving you almost a literary
argument you know i'm gonna write these
20 books about human nature and you go
read them but just just humor me when
you read them just pretend that they're
true and use apply them to your life and
see whether it's revealing or not and
through that process the the real force
of proof comes from
revelation right it becomes revelatory
that it's able to explain phenomena and
direct you in ways that actually end up
working
um
that's the first thing i'll say and
that's where the power of drug really
came from me and how i got convinced was
introspection uh
but in terms of mimesis there actually
has been uh empirical work done on this
um i'm blanking on the name of the
of the uh scientists but uh
there was studies of babies and they
showed how
you know
babies started imitating the facial
features of
of humans
of other adults ever since you know 25
minutes old
um
and there's
you know i think in the late 20th
century there was a big boom in
neuroscience with mirror neurons
and some gerardians have used that as
the biological basis of mimesis um so so
there are sort of those empirical routes
that one can take and i think uh you
know if i dedicated my life to studying
this that i i really should take
but for me at least to answer the
question of why gerard was worth
engaging for me the sort of
introspection um was more than enough
for me to continue engaging
it seems like gerard's view of human
nature is um
not
not um
as vulnerable or fallible it seems like
we're incredibly fallible in his eyes oh
terribly so i would say so but talk to
me
you've read his work it's been hugely
influential on you it's taken you from
being this sort of super rational stem
person to a slightly less rational but
perhaps a little bit more rounded
philosophy person
how
how do you feel
um enlightened or fulfilled by a theory
which kind of points the finger at you
and says how easily fallible you are
yeah i think that's a that's a great
question um
and i can give two answers
one is
um how has that changed my view
to uh society and the other is how has
it changed my view to myself
um and i'll answer the first one first
because i think it's more interesting
what gerard is doing here is he's giving
us a theodicy as you can see and as we
already covered in the brief 30 40
minutes he thinks that humans to your
point are deeply fallible so much so
that he's giving us a psychology of
original sin what it means to be fallen
creatures right this idea that we're
motivated by an unrelenting drive that
we can never satisfy um that we we're
not even aware of that we say we want to
be an investment banker but we really
don't want that we want something else
that's a terrible terrible thing right
and
it only gets worse and worse there's so
many different social pathologies like
math
or psychological social pathologies like
masochism and bipolarity that gerard
identifies as not just contingent not
not as accidental but as always existing
in human nature
gerard rejects this uh modern second
analytical approach to label certain
diseases as discrete things you know
you're schizophrenic or not you're
bipolar you're not instead he sees all
of human nature as one of on a degree of
pathology that we're all masochistic
we're all bipolar
now
i would actually argue and this might be
but might be weird but hear me out that
this is quite a liberating and hopeful
way to to view society
um and the reason is
um let me give you let me give you an
example so gerard's argument for why you
know alienation and fetishization you
know these are two concepts that uh
marxist thinkers are very concerned with
um his gerard's argument is that both of
these things
are not due to the structure of capital
but due to the structure of human nature
and i think it's very easy to see right
what is fetishization it's a desire for
the object more than what the object can
give us well that's just metaphysical
desire right and what is alienation it's
alienating the best qualities of
ourselves into an object reasoning once
we get close to that object we will
attain it again that's just metaphysical
desire
and so gerard would say to a marxist for
example
um that you know you're right in
identifying that alienation and
fetishization exists in contemporary
capitalism and you're even right that
they're channeled through capitalism but
you'd be deluded in thinking that
they're caused by capitalism their roots
are much deeper in fundamental human
condition and that is what happened when
people try to liberate themselves from
capitalism right the alien nation uh
from the pro the process of labor in
british coal mines became the alienation
from the soviet factories
and so
uh what gerard is doing here is given a
fundamentally fallen picture of human
nature that sees
many
social pathologies
as natural to the human condition but
then i know chris the question in your
mind must be why is jonathan saying that
this is a good thing why is it helping
him reconcile it with the world
it allows us to see the world and
say
this is all that humans can be and
allows us to affirm it
let me give you the opposite sort of uh
argument here you know
you know i i heard this one uh uh you
know progressive newspaper line uh about
sort of asians being very upset that
their names were mispronounced
um and you know obviously i you know as
as an immigrant myself i've had those
experiences and it doesn't feel good but
what i found really odd
about that argument is that
people can't really
make certain sounds after the critical
stage of language acquisition of seven
right so what what they're upset about
that you know uh europeans or people who
grew up in european languages can't
pronounce certain chinese sounds like
my name india is actually very hard to
pronounce like people have really
tremendous trouble they say g instead of
dia um
so i'm you know i i've been through this
but i would have found really odd about
this progressive article
is uh they're really complaining about
something that really can't be changed
right because
critical language acquisitions happen
you know it
ends at age seven so so you you really
there's no possible world where people
do pronounce all of
asian names perfectly correctly
and i think what is underlying a lot of
contemporary progressivism today
is
uh a overly optimistic view of human
nature right and gerard would attribute
this view to rousseau
this sort of perfected state of nature
that society corrupts
now whereas
uh uh does that make sense yeah so so so
it's the the original sin as it gives us
a lowered expectation of what we can
expect from ourselves in society to make
our existing society actually
affirmable by reason so that we don't go
and look at the first sign of alienation
or fetishization or impression
inequality and say we've got to tear the
whole system down and i think that's a
common
intuition a common critical intuition
into contemporary society okay so
the fact that fundamentally in gerard's
theory he sees humans as fallible
creatures kind of fallen he gets into
theology a little bit later in his
career as well and i imagine that he's
drawn some quite nice lines between his
psychology and his theology work
the fact that he's got that
is like a meta comment around the fact
that humans are his view of human nature
is fallible and the solution to our
fallibility is first to recognize the
fact that we are fallible so the red
pill that he's shoving down everybody's
throats is like it's the thing that they
need to actually be able to understand
in order for them to be able to see the
i guess the
i just i just hoped that we would be
more hopeful you know like being told
that
i'm ruthlessly at the mercy of the high
status people in my society and i'm
either going to positively go toward
what they want or negatively go away
from whatever the opposite of those
people are what they want
it
how have you talked to me about you
practical applicable ways that you
operate in your life in a girardian
sense
yeah so um maybe let me make just one
more comment about this sort of social
theodocy that we've been talking about
um the first thing i'll say is
gerard thinks that human nature is
fundamentally fallen so there's a limit
to the to the goodness of a society that
we can build but certainly that does not
mean that we can that we should just
stomach all forms of badness certainly
that does not mean we look at slavery
and we say oh there's oppression
everywhere you know let's move on let's
affirm that that is not the case i think
what gerard is doing is more negative
he's saying
if you take a perfectable view of human
nature
um
no society that you're gonna design is
really gonna live up to that and you're
gonna end in this critical loophole
where you're gonna start critiquing
everything and think that it's
sufficient for the impetus of change
well that is not so but i just wanted to
clarify that that this sort of uh this
sort of argument is not uh also an
argument for complacency but just
placing a fundamental limit on how good
a human society can be
um
in terms of your in terms of your other
question i i think this is probably my
fault i probably
exaggerated uh the determinism
of
uh that that gerard attributes to
humanity um i think maybe
this is gonna be reductive but i think
hopefully illuminating the one liner
here is um
we have agency in choosing our social
circumstance
but not necessarily how we will behave
in those social circumstances if that
makes sense does this go back to the
john boyd example about the fact that
you can foresee things okay so the
argument here is that mimesis and our
desire to be like the people that are
successful and push away from the people
that aren't
these are
very difficult for us to deprogram if
possible at all
one of the choices that we have is to
retreat to a cabin in the woods and and
completely [ __ ] off
right another solution is for us to
stack the deck in our favor
with the
foresight that mimetic desire is going
to come through and the way that we
stack the deck is to be around people
that we genuinely want ourselves to be
like
is that right
kind of
kind of um
so
yes it's it's fundamentally the the
conclusion of gerard is one must design
one's social environment
right um how in one way yeah so so
one way and this is necessary social
again i'll emphasize is to do what you
like physical desire because again
physical metaphors are our competing
interests right take the example of
joseph campbell hero of a thousand faces
he uh basically left his phd program at
columbia i i think and he just went into
the woods and it read for 10 years
now he was only able to do that without
any social validation because he loved
the activity in and of itself and for me
and gerard for a period at least that
was how i felt about gerrard i wasn't
thinking about going on these podcasts
or or working on a book length project
but it was
it was so helpful and illuminating and
fun for me to wrestle with gerard into
the mud um that that i i would be fine
with little social affirmation and i
feel i think you see this with dating as
well right i mean some people they
clearly want partners so that other
people can see
them with them and that's where they
derive most of the value trophy wives or
husbands are the most extreme example of
this but if you find someone that you
genuinely love hanging out in and of
itself and this goes the same for
friendships then then you can diminish
the amount you have to lean on uh
those memetic impulses
what about desires that we have physical
desires that
aren't adaptive or are malignant or
shouldn't be there that need that
mimetic sense to curb some of them so
let's say that somebody likes stealing
they love the thrill of
robbing other stores
the mimetic impulse that they have from
other people who say maybe you shouldn't
do that that's a good influence that's
tamping down a physical desire that
somebody has which actually needs
restricting and in that way the mimesis
is something that they shouldn't try and
avoid but something that they should
actually try and lean into yeah yeah
gerard gerard doesn't bring these uh
punitive or corrective examples up of a
lot um and i frankly i haven't thought a
lot about them but i think that would be
uh
that would be a good solution in fact
the sort of closest thing that i thought
about of
given the example that you gave was
actually about how to educate my future
children
um and you know it's very hard for
people to love knowledge in and of
itself you know some some people
eventually get there but in order to do
so you're gonna have to do a lot of
training
right
to get there and that training is often
not enjoyable at all so i think this
mimetic desire desire to be
um can be that impulse that drive to get
you over that hump so those physical
desires can come in and that's very
close to your example here right the
memetic forces are acting as a crutch if
you will before those physical desires
come in and another good example here is
chris as i'm sure you know is is working
out or weightlifting or any form of
sports it's quite unsatisfying for the
first few months when you're doing a
sport because you're not very good at it
um but if you have a desire to be if you
want to be like ronaldo or messi or you
know lebron james uh that the man can
get you over the hump again uh this is
us
creatively uh interpreting gerard which
i'm all a fan of but gerard himself
is very clear that even in these
instances metaphysical desire is still
fundamentally bad because it's still
fundamentally motivated by a lie but
that's not to say it can have very
important and positive consequences
yeah it's
it's strange to think about
what are the impacts that you get from
other people
that pull you along in a good way so for
instance going to the gym
a lot of people might go to the gym
because of the way that it makes them
look to other people now the byproduct
of them going to the gym and them
looking good to other people they're
going to be healthier they're going to
live longer they're going to have higher
bone density and muscle mass and the
myriad of things that you get out of
exercise but
that is i guess that that's just a fluke
that's a fluke that the metaphysical
desire of the signal that going to the
gym and the sort of body that you get
happens to align with something which is
physically good for yourself and
i would guess the sort of uh race to the
bottom and the way that
groups of people tend to converge on
stuff a lot of the time the metaphysical
desire that emerges as a collective
isn't necessarily what's optimal for the
individual on their own there's a a blog
post called what do you want to want by
kyle eschenroder and i
must i must quote it once a week to
people right and he read it he asks the
question
what do you want to want now that's a
really interesting question not what do
you want
what do you want to want what are the
desires that you want yourself to have
and it's the same as the is it
aristotle or seneca or someone that says
uh if a man knows not where he sails no
wind is favorable
right and the problem that you have is
you can't turn the wind off right
there's always going to be wind and
there's always going to be destinations
but if you're not careful if you don't
look at your desires if you don't assess
where you are and genuinely what you
want to want from life you can end up in
a place not only that you didn't mean to
get to but you don't even want to be
yes and so
that's that's all great and i think
you're hitting on core gerardian
intuitions and the landscape where he
discusses this is actually in uh the
political culture of the day so the long
story short is that in pagan society he
thinks that there was memetic pressures
to kill victims and in contemporary
society there's memetic pressure to
protect victims
now gerard would say that today someone
uh uh you know who's trying to protect
victims out of mimesis
is fundamentally better than someone
converging to a worse form of mimesis
trying to kill victims but it's still
mimesis nonetheless and maybe to project
it into your example that you gave we
can say that uh maybe a good outcome
is if
metaphysical desire
overlays with with physical desire um
however insofar as you are pushed by
metaphysical desire i would wager that
you are not fully your own man or woman
because
if the
as you say the winds slightly tilt
another way and instead of you know
working out it's
i don't know jumping off a cliff or
something like that
then you will be equally lean towards
that so to your point the the success is
is trivial or accidental now another
problem that comes with this approach of
being motivated by metaphysical desire
even if it's to a direction that you
want is twofold one you may overdo the
thing right think about uh you know
bodybuilders injecting uh you know
uh if you don't do it for health you're
doing it for to show off then you can
easily go above and beyond what health
dictates and actually harm your health
as you well know um and
the other thing and this is
i think why gerard thinks it's
fundamentally bad
is it's very tiring to be motivated that
by that force and i think
anyone who's been motivated by such a
social force
can discuss can discuss that or can
relate to this that when you lose it's a
sort of existential despair
and when you win it's not sort of a
over abundant overflowing everlasting
joy but almost a sense of relief
and so we may say that it's better for
metaphysical desire to be directed at
good things and to align your physical
desire there's still fundamental
problems with being motivated by it or
at the very least it's too much
in that same blog post what you want to
want he talks about how other people's
heads
is a terrible place for your self-worth
to live that a lot of the time when
people do things now they're not doing
them for the joy of themselves they're
doing them for what it says about them
they're doing it for the tweets that are
then subsequently going to come or the
likes or the comments on an instagram
page and
it is incredibly fragile when you think
about the fact that you could do
something
not because you want to do it but
because you think other people will like
the fact that you've done it
that does basically put your entire
sense of self-worth and fulfillment and
direction in life in the hands of other
people now
i had a discussion with michael mallis
my mate and he said
he believes that a large proportion of
the population
fundamentally doesn't have agency or a
personality and
that these people are better off trying
to model people that have been
successful because if they were left to
their own devices they would get things
wrong he has a very uh uh even
less um hopefully
i think of human nature than than gerard
does but his point is
as far as he's concerned a lot of people
are idiots and therefore they would [ __ ]
up if you left them on their own what
they need to do
is to actually model off people that do
know what they're doing because that's
going to have this trickle-down effect
of at least making the people at the
bottom a little bit less [ __ ]
yeah you know um
this is i think
if i may reframe our conversation as any
annoying analytical philosopher does
we've discussed before how can
metaphysical desire even though
ultimately bad be good for the
individual
right that it can you know push us to
work out and get us over the hump where
physical desire can take over but now i
think what you're asking is but how can
it be good for society
and this is a question that gerard
himself really has to wrestle with
because gerard uh despite being a
christian believes in human evolution
and so there must be a functional value
it's going to be adaptive or
metaphysical desire
and what is that functional value gerard
basically thinks uh or rather i think i
read into gerard that
metaphysical desire and mimesis
help us
uh organize in very very large groups
have you ever read sapiens by any chance
yes
yeah so so in it right it describes a
competition between homo erectus uh
neanderthal to us homo sapien and i
think one of the big differences i may
butcher this is that erectus and homo
sapiens i'm sorry erectus and
neanderthal can only
uh organize up to a certain limit
right this is i don't know if it's
dunbar's number but there's a
fundamental limit
whereas humanity is able to or we're
still seven million people and we're
still somewhat successfully organized
what is that
gerard's answer here is that
we are not special as creatures because
of our ability to gain access to truth
animals do this all the time echo
echolocation magnetic fields we are
special because we can believe in lies
in so far as we look around and see
other people believing in lies as well
now the less provocative way of saying
that is we can use mimesis to spin up
helpful fictions
the greek gods
fiat money cryptocurrencies to organize
massive amounts of society
and and to sort of structure society
beyond dunbar's number it's our ability
to believe in lies and
follow the herd that that is what got
humanity here today and one more thing
that i would like to point your readers
to
excellent book written by by the
professor i studied with called
rousseau's theodicy and rousseau
identifies a very similar drive uh like
metaphysical desire and mimesis he
called it a more prop the desire for
self is for esteem for social
recognition
and to quote him i'm going to paraphrase
to this we must attribute all of our
rapists all of our criminals all the
worst of humanity but also our
entrepreneurs our artists and our great
generals to this drive all of humanity
when we make humanity uh interesting we
must attribute and that is really how
core the mises and metaphysical desire
is that it can be amazing for societies
that it could be
greatly helpful of individuals but
gerard thinks it is ultimately
suffocating for the person who is
motivated by it
one of the first times i think i ever
heard gerard be spoken about was peter
thiel so i recently went and facilitated
a conversation with him a couple of
weeks ago which was very nice he was
very lovely we had a good chat um but
i wonder
why it is that so many people in
positions of power hold gerard in
high regard he's like the sort of hot
new girl philosopher of silicon valley
at the moment
yeah um
that's true and i think you know the
first thing i'll say is that there's
probably a form of memetic memetic
theory going on here um that uh and this
is certainly how i got into memetic
theory is uh wanting to be like peter
right uh and obviously i had other role
models growing up you know george soros
ray dalio the these people who are able
to combine um
you know very interesting ways of
thinking with worldly action but peter
was definitely up there and i definitely
got into gerard in the very beginning uh
through
through peter and and and i think that's
true for probably most people you see um
of wanting to to be like him now this
isn't this is quite interesting a
phenomenon i would say
because
you know any other theory
to say that
you like it just because other people
like it
is uh a negative to that theory oh you
know you you just like uh david greater
because other people like david graver
but one is hard to say the same about
memetic theory because that's exactly
what memetic theory predicts
right because if you're saying like look
memetic theory really has very little
value
then you're like well why do people like
it oh because other people like it then
you're like well then it does have a lot
of value [ __ ] unfalsifiable man i
told you this earlier yeah yeah
um now
the the the other thing that i'll say
here is
uh i i think we shouldn't shy away from
such a genealogy for example that you
know i got into a thing uh because of
mediation um as we've discussed already
with uh education with uh working out
many of the times we we do get into with
a thing not knowing what the physical
experience is right and it's almost a
tautology because how can you know the
thing is before you get into it
um now i think what's important is
whether you uh whether you're still
mediated by that right
going forward or
like me you know you just gained a love
for the subject itself
but i think there's another answer
beyond this and i think we'd be giving
peter too much credit if we say you know
it's just peter
now my answer isn't going to take the
shape of saying
there's something important and crucial
by memetic theory which i think there is
that makes people successful
instead i think that there is a
confounding variable that leads people
botus both to success and memetic theory
does the shape of my answer before i
actually give it makes sense that it's
not that my theory gives us something
it's that something leads people who are
already predisposed to success to
mimetic theory and i think the answer
there is arrogance and pride and
delusion
now i'm gonna have to give you two
arguments here why i think that's
necessary for worldly success or helpful
for worldly success and the other is you
know why people like that are attracted
to gerard i'll give the second one first
it's easier to give
as we mentioned this desire to be
metaphysical desire is a yearning to
exist in great measure i think then the
gerard psychology is incredibly limited
and what it describes really really well
is the psychology of the prideful person
think about it what are gerard's
canonical examples claushuits
holderlin napoleon
uh don quixote right the casanovas and
the coquettes of the world people who
are really really prideful and the type
of psychology that gerard describes you
know
envy at the slightest a tremor and
existential despair as
you know you glance at your friend and
he's doing slightly better than you well
while some of us may share that to a
degree it's only the people who are
extremely prideful
who sort of really experienced that
so gerard is really giving us the
psychology of pride here
and i think uh people who are naturally
prideful and arrogant such as myself
when i came to gerard
we naturally gravitate towards this
theory because it explains us so well
you know nietzsche tells us that uh you
know the philosophies we choose to write
far beyond an objective capture of human
nature is actually a deeply subjective
confession of who we actually are
well i will add to that then so must be
the philosophies we choose to read
right we naturally gravitate towards the
types of psychology that and
phenomenological experience that
conforms to our own and so i think uh
people who are prideful and arrogant are
more attracted to gerard uh because
um
that he describes a psychology of pride
now
you know i have to proceed on my uh
second prong of my argument for why i
think because i i've drawn the link with
pride to memetic theory now i have to
draw the link between pride and worldly
success
and
i think the way i'm going to do this is
is by drawing um
an example or let me give you a few
examples why i think pride arrogance
delusion are it's not necessarily
certainly helpful for worldly success
um think about
what you would have said if you were
elon's friend and he told you he wanted
to not only you know change the way that
cars were powered but also send rocket
to mars right think about uh what you'd
have said to
to peter and joe when they were starting
pallents here and this is what people
said you're going to sell government you
just sell the cia software that's
ridiculous
right and you know this is not only true
for worldly action in industry but also
for philosophy you know so i've been
told you know adorno and horkheimer the
founders of the frankfurt school you
know tremendous influence on the
political left uh were extremely
arrogant you know believing themselves
and their thirties to have cognized
um uh sort of that you know the
fundamental logic of philosophy or
something like that and in my own life
uh you know i would consider myself
somewhat successful and again all the
most important moves right i was a
middling school student in china going
to a public school in canada
and i wanted to get an ivy league i
wanted to study cs as an international
kid and i wanted a full ride
and i was delusional and people thought
that i was delusional the same thing
with gerard you know as a 20 year old
you're going to tell me you're going to
read all of gerard's canon by yourself
and you're going to create a lecture
series and you're going to title you
have the arrogance to title your book
completing gerard as your as your first
look what ridiculous arrogance is that
we'll see whether this ends up being a
laughingstock or not but
the point is it's almost in the nature
of success
to conceive of oneself as greater than
one currently is
to be prideful to be arrogant to be
delusional
and i think we can find philosophical
grounding for this argument in one of my
favorite essays nietzsche's uh uses and
abuses of history for life in it he
argues the fundamental place of action
in the world comes from a place of
untruth
a delusion in one's ability and a
delusion in how important achieving that
thing is going to make me feel and a
delusion in the importance of that thing
to the world we need to be diluted to
have that extra boost to carry it
forward and i think once framed in this
slide this actually ties back very
nicely to what we discussed about
metaphysical desire if you're just in
there
to lift
to be healthy but i'm lifting because
this nature of my existence is dependent
on it
then i'm probably going to beat you
because i'm just going to be so much
more motivated now gerard thinks that
i'm going to have a worse life than you
but that but we're not talking about
good or bad lives we're talking about
worldly success here right so that is
the shape of my argument that there's a
layer of mimesis uh mostly through peter
that brings people into gerardian theory
and people stay there because it
captures the psychology of pride which
is also what i think to be unnecessary
if not deeply helpful psychology for
worldly success
well pride and arrogance are one hell of
a fuel source to drive you forward and
of course
you're right that
the interesting thing about imposter
syndrome is that
a lot of the time it's justified
especially when you're trailblazing this
is what seth godin said he's like look
if you've never done a thing before
imposter syndrome isn't some maladaptive
psychological trait it's a realistic
positioning of your capacities and the
challenges that you're coming up against
right now the problem is if you continue
to disprove it in the real world and
then it persists that's impostor
adaptation which is a malignant version
of it but imposter syndrome is just you
knowing what you've done before and then
looking at the challenge in front of you
and going
i haven't done that i i don't really
know so what you're saying is that
arrogance pride sort of a self-belief
deceit
all of this what it does is it enables
to people
people to think above and beyond
what their capacities are now in the
current moment yes
precisely and and again right this can
go terribly terribly wrong and for each
elon we can point to you know
a hundred elizabeth home selection like
that whatever is survivorship by
survivorship bias right so so
i'm not making the argument that you
know all you have to do is be delusional
and prideful you obviously have to be
very very skilled to eventually justify
that delusion but i think the argument
i'm making is that you know that that
specific forms of delusion of untruth of
a refusal to meet with reality in the
moment is deeply deeply uh you know
helpful for worldly activity well it
seems to be that way you know you see or
hear these guys speak and i think this
is as well one of the reasons why when
people hear you know george soros or
bill gates or these you know people that
have become incredibly wealthy or
powerful when they hear them speak there
is a little bit of a a suspicion that
they're part of some reptilian race or a
new world order that's trying to take
over everything because it seems quite
detached right remember that these
people have selected for the top one
percent of the top one percent of the
top one percent of pretty much
everything that you need to get yourself
there in fact cool story one of my
friends in austin works for a
recruitment company recruiting
high-powered executives for startups
right so this guy has access to
the hitters of the hitters for the
biggest companies and the fastest
growing startups in the world and he was
telling me that he was able to go into
the files that they had
and go back to see a bunch of executives
that are now at huge companies and read
their files from five or ten years ago
so the way that they do their
interviews is they sit down for between
five and ten hours and they just talk
there's a framework that they follow but
it's not
qualifications and stuff it's
personality it's attributes it's traits
right and i was like okay so tell me
what it's like could you go back
and see that the people that are super
successful now were going to be super
successful so that's interesting yes you
can
the people that get to
you don't get onto this list without
being some sort of beast but the people
that were the absolute best
stood out
way before in a five hour or ten hour
conversation they already stood out
amongst a sea of incredibly competent
people as being superbly competent so he
said he went back and looked at tim cook
that they'd had now the ceo apple and
the first word on tim cook's report was
stood
the first word was stood susanna was
jiki that looks after youtube rockstar
was the first word on that he's like
this isn't how most peoples were written
so you were able to see that the hitters
of the hitters were already going to do
it they stood out in the space of five
hours
and
was how does this tie back to our
current conversation
you're saying that uh you're saying that
their arrogance or pride even at that
moment was somewhat justified or like
it's not justified by their current
achievement by their clear potential yes
precisely like most people that go into
a job interview they're trying to play
themselves up but i don't know whether
even the most competent person would
come out with rockstar or stud
written on their on their interview
notes but you're going like you have to
exude a degree of self belief and
confidence and the other thing is that
everybody else knows that they need to
play up their skills too
so this person is having to pitch
themselves above and beyond not only
where they're at not only where
everybody else is at but
even higher than that again and this
isn't saying that tim cook went and lied
during his interview but just the fact
that he was able to and and these people
that are interviewing him they're
trained at picking out shysters right
they're trained at picking out people
that are selling snake oil and
they didn't find any
and then tim cook goes on to be the ceo
of apple and then suzanna goes on to go
and look after youtube
yeah
yeah
the one thing i'd be curious to
to to go back and see of all the ones
that started with stud and rockstar what
were the false negatives but that that's
a separate that's a separate thing um
i think you know maybe to give give your
listeners another gerardian insight here
gerard
is very interested in why narcissism is
such a great mating strategy
uh in both men and women uh and men you
know it's a bit more obvious but in
women it's the
truck of diseases as a coquette like the
fundamental uh woman seducer right
where's the man it's the don juan
and gerard's analysis is quite
interesting
for most of us you know our metaphysical
desires are pointed outwards
we want to be
tim cook we want to be you know we want
to run youtube
but for the narcissist
the gerard describes them as their
desires pointing inwards
as a desire for themselves of who they
already are that they're already full
and mimesis comes into play because you
then imitate that desire
and so the way to translate that into
plain language is
if i'm confident in myself
then you're going to be like
what does he know about himself right
it's kind of like that example with the
with the guy and the hot woman where the
hot women know and said here it's one
person
what does he know about himself why is
he so confident
and and so i think again it's these like
revelatory sort of insights in one
logical framework that slowly sort of
converts you rather than any sort of you
know empirical proof
what's the main thing that people should
take away from today
yeah
maybe maybe it's not the key thing of a
memetic theory a key thread
um
underlying all of our discussions today
and why i imagine as a listener it might
be so unsatisfying is is that we live if
gerard is correct in a deeply ambivalent
world
right we live in a world where
uh
this fundamental motivational force can
bring civilizations in an entire species
into prosperity and glory where it can
uh bring you to new heights but it's
also something that can uh you know pull
you down make you existently frustrated
that can direct you and so maybe the one
thing to take away is that there's
there's no real simple answers here uh
and unlike gerard i don't think this
metaphysical desire is something we
always must renounce um it's something i
think much more similar to what you're
saying that i'm actually experimenting
and playing around with
maybe the last thing i'll leave us with
then is that uh you know we live in a
world of uh very difficult trade-offs
um and and life is about fundamentally
understanding the parameters and
navigating those trade-offs
jonathan b ladies and gentlemen you've
got a new lecture series out that is on
gerard where can people get that
uh on my website
let's include it in in the show notes
we're gonna release one episode uh every
you know let's say five to seven weeks
first episode is all out already we
would love to hear what people think
about
that's gonna be linked in the show notes
below jonathan i appreciate you man and
uh next time that we're out in austin
we'll have a fight with a hobo and and
get some tacos and stuff done
awesome thanks chris what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace